we have a very interesting voicemail
today it's about Michael Bloomberg and
this is actually something that people
have been emailing me about as well our
friend Ben Dixon unearthed a horrible
horrible audio of Michael Bloomberg
talking about black people and stop and
frisk and it's it's really really bad to
someone with more progressive
sensibilities but this caller and some
people who have been emailing are
arguing that this might actually be good
for Michael Bloomberg in some parts of
the country let's take a listen yeah
just a few words here on the Bloomberg
polling data
he recently talked about Sally I
actually think that audio recordings
helps Bloomberg's campaign from indice
Lee not only in a state like mine which
is Texas with a lot of with the growing
moderate population of Democrats but
throughout the lower mason-dixon my
worry is that Bloomberg picks up
center-left voters as well as people on
the right who see Bloomberg as half the
height and doubled up everything skills
of Trump
my question to you is does this does
this concern you and Bernie's campaign
be more proactive in getting in front of
all of us before it gets out of hand
before that there's a larger narrative
that interact from this yes so the risk
for Bernie of starting to go after
Michael Bloomberg right now is that as
of yet Michael Bloomberg has gotten zero
in every primary because he's just
ignored the first four primaries and if
you're Bernie's strategist I don't know
that you feel it's a good idea to start
going after someone who hasn't been in a
single debate and who hasn't received a
single vote yet at the same time there's
no question Pope the polling suggests
Bloomberg is going to do okay on Super
Tuesday I don't know that I agree that
the racist audio will be good for
Bloomberg in the primary because there
there's no question and we got some
calls on our Tuesday night stream there
are voters who just don't care about the
racist Bloomberg audio they have a sort
of he's better than Trump and he
actually is a good business person and
I'd vote for him sort of mentality
people who don't care about the racist
audio I don't know that there are too
many Democratic primary voters who are
going to say Oh
estádio I'm going to go and vote for
Michael Bloomberg especially because it
seems to me that a lot of those more
racists of voters number one may not be
voting in the Democratic primary at all
and number two they may also be
anti-semitic and they may not vote for
Michael Bloomberg because he's Jewish so
I don't know that I I buy that but I do
think there's a very good chance that
the racist audio doesn't do a
significant damage to Michael Bloomberg
let me know what you think we've got a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about who benefits the most from
Andrew yang dropping out of the
presidential race we're going to talk
about a Utah bill decriminalizing
polygamy which has actually cleared its
first hurdle and we will also talk about
more disgusting revelations related to
Congressman Jim Jordan all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
get access instantly by becoming a
member at join pakman.com or becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show